we're gonna be counting down big cats
Super Bowls storylines we're gonna start
with number 5 it relates to a certain
head coach who is coming back to a
certain place where he spent a certain
amount of time as a youth take it away
big cat
so you Mike you are the journalist here
Chris and I watched the X's and O's but
journalists usually bury every single
Super Bowl storyline to the point where
we don't want to hear about it anymore
so I'm pre burying it before we even get
to Atlanta let's just hammer home these
storylines that we don't have to hear it
anymore
exactly John McVay is from Georgia that
is a fact
he won the 2003 Georgia State Player of
the Year over Calvin Johnson amazing won
a state title in the Georgia Dome which
is obviously not around anymore he
dominated high school football in the
state of Georgia so we as journalists
have to talk about it non-stop and
remind everyone at every point when were
in Atlanta that Sean McVeigh is in fact
from Georgia yes
he's the natural apparently this is the
great homecoming story of a great high
school legend yes I actually am
surprised I did not know he was this
good of a football player and all you
had to say to me was he beat out Calvin
Johnson and you had me sold right there
that's it right there and there also is
the story line that Sean McVeigh played
against Julian Edelman in college Miami
verse Toledo Julian Edelman was of
course a quarterback Sean McVeigh a wide
receiver so we have that as a little
ancillary story line from Sean McVeigh's
football career so basically you're
getting ahead of these storylines now
because they're going to be everything
that we hear about all of next week when
we're all in Atlanta where Sean McVeigh
coincidentally happened to be a football
star as a youth that's where it all
started here on pft line it's another
big cat super both storyline big cat
what do you got it number four so Sony
Michelle played at the University of
Georgia if you remember his last game as
a bulldog
was in the what is the mercedes-benz
domes right where they don't serve
chick-fil-a on Sundays it was in this
dome and it was the house of horrors for
him because Alabama famously comes back
in the game
Georgia has a lead
22:10 in the fourth quarter two of comes
in and steals the national championship
from the Georgia Bulldogs so Sony
Michele a homecoming of sorts for him
and we just have to go we have to just
basically pile up all the homecoming so
that you have something to talk about
all week Mike well and you know I hadn't
even thought of that one because I don't
pay it nearly as much attention to
college football's I do to the NFL so
thank you for giving me that in advance
I I will be able to ask all guests next
week when we're down at radio row four
PFT live about Sony Michele coming back
to Georgia worlds are colliding he's
coming back to Georgia you know kind of
eradicate a negative thing Sean McVeigh
coming back to Georgia to advance a
positive and oh somebody is going to be
happy and somebody's going to be sad and
one more thing about McVeigh that we
didn't talk about earlier I think we
talked about it during the break the
idea that McVeigh actually attended
Super Bowl 34 with his dad or something
like that and they got stuck in the ice
storm and that yeah I'm surprised that
hasn't made your list it's not on the
look at it's not unless the ice storm I
wanted to set you up so that you could
come are yeah good job we need to be
checking the forecast there could be
another ice storm we're getting you a
few or early easy throws okay I mean you
talk about all the time can you feel
good yeah you feel like a real
journalist right now Mike I I do I do I
feel like I'm I have full credentials
unlike some and I will be able to do we
know anything about your credentials for
the Super Bowl has any FedEx adia FedEx
or anything yet last year we saw the
little there was a little piece of paper
at radio row and it had all of our names
on it and said do not credential these
three people do you Hank and myself
yeah and I would assume that it's gonna
be similar this year yeah keep that
riffraff out of there you know these
guys you can't control them but
seriously though the so many Michele
thing's pretty awesome that's going back
to like exorcise the demons of the
national championship and then like he's
the man right now I mean come on the New
England Patriots we want to talk about
Tom Brady and Belichick and they're
awesome don't get me wrong but they
literally play through the running game
right now that we saw again on the AFC
Championship it is about Sony Michele
running
the tackles and everything off of that
so that's a pretty cool story for him as
a rookie to be a part of this see his
work I'm waiting for one on the ice
storm and there's one other story line
that goes back to the last Atlanta Super
Bowl that I hope is not on your list I
don't know let's just leave it right
there yeah and we'll be back with more
PFT live at after number 52 time for
story line number three from big cat a
fake story line that by some radio host
may be considered as a real storyline
take it away big cat well todd gurley
seemingly has the referees in his pocket
because you see the famous it's actually
it's famous in soccer in Europe where
they swap jerseys sometimes in football
they do it but todd gurley swapped
jerseys with the ref after the game this
is a real picture totally unethical by
the referees I cannot believe he did
this so the story line will be will Todd
Gurley still have the refs in his pocket
and is he mad at CJ Anderson because he
didn't get enough carries like Micah
said that's the better storyline huh
look I I appreciate I appreciate the use
of the very real photo of Bill vinovich
and Todd Gurley swapping Jersey
something that actually did happen on
the field after the game even though
Bill vinovich apparently showed up with
two jerseys one that he gave to Todd
Gurley and one that he was still wearing
in the photo which is kind of amazing I
mean maybe those things are so tight you
can just layer them yep but the the Todd
Gurley CJ Anderson thing is gonna be
real because think about it all the
media availabilities whether it's the
one hour on Monday night whether it's
all the various other times these guys
have to answer questions they parade
them in front of microphones all week
long you know it's gonna be asked about
Todd Gurley you know Todd Gurley upset
that CJ Anderson is getting these reps
is he healthy as he not healthy why
didn't they play him more that's not
going away
and that is going to be something that
dominates all of these press conferences
that start as soon as it gets a town on
Sunday night guys okay he's gonna go off
on the Super Bowl I just he's a talented
player he's more talented than CJ
Anderson I do think it's hilarious that
there was a certain New York radio host
that really thought that was a real
picture like he couldn't believe that
the referee did that it is
picture a real picture but the other
thing is this I gotta give Todd Gurley
at least he called himself out after the
game he said he played like crap
they said he was sorry he said he was
sorry like that night that's refreshing
this day and age and the Millennials
where they just you know take the
responsibility and deal with it you're a
millennial i'm like borderlining girls
are older Melissa yes exactly
Super Bowl box drama clay for for
bringing in a ring and maybe having that
conversation
the only thing maybe you went a little
too far with was his first play the game
but everything else I can go okay that's
a big cat my Internet son PFT commenter
with Sean McVeigh in the back of their
van before the season started and I I
don't think this is actually gonna be a
storyline next week I think this is
wishful thinking on your heart to get
Sean McVeigh time honor the promise to
put you in a box give you a ring and
possibly call the first plot wouldn't
trust me with the first place well no I
wouldn't trust myself because I've
already stated that if I did have the
first play I would have Jared Goff run
backwards into the endzone first safety
and I'd bet all the money that I have
you are so wrong because we're on NBC
Sports right now and it's a storyline
look at that look at that it says Sean
McVeigh owes podcasters a Super Bowl
suite ring and possibly first play call
I am reading that literally on NBC
Sports I have just incepted the
storyline I knew you were gonna do that
you played right in my hand
you said there's no way that's gonna be
a storyline boom it's a storyline I I
mean it's a lot they're asking I mean
PFT and big cat I mean they're asking
for a sweet a ring in the first play and
they Jam the guy in the back of the car
and they were sitting there rubbin
thighs together I mean that's what he
gets out of this racing it's smart you
asked for everything and then if you get
anything it's more than you were
otherwise gonna get it's good
negotiation you start high and if you
just get the ring out of it it's a
pretty good day yeah first they gotta
win the Super Ball will we've ever more
right after this
[Music]
continuing with big cats Super Bowl
storylines the number-one storyline will
be hearing for the next 11 days take it
away big cat it is the number one
storyline you'll be hearing I can
guarantee you that Mike you will write
many blogs on it
the Patriots started this dynasty run
against the Rams in the Super Bowl they
are back against the Rams in the Super
Bowl and it's however many years later
19 18 years later will this be the
retirement tour for Tom Brady and Bill
Belichick I don't think so but I think
it's actually something that's worthy of
throwing out there because if Tom Brady
wins this game what else does he have to
prove right walk out do the John Elway
yeah and just go off into the sunset I
hear that I mean the only thing I could
say that like he has left to prove is
maybe he just wants to one-up Michael
Jordan to become that guy with like
seven change or never lost I know you're
right I know but I'm just saying that's
the one thing yeah I'm with you like it
doesn't need to end Brady can still has
the hundred mile per hour fastball like
we've seen and it's amazing that what
we've talked about what they've done
through this through this whole streak
yeah I don't think it will I'll be on
the record I do not think Tom Brady's
gonna retire but it's worthy of just
throwing out there and it's also the
bookend of how long this has lasted yeah
starting with the Rams
now we're batting they couldn't even
drink alcohol he was half the game or in
this superbunny that's 17 years to the
day it'll be when they play in the Super
Bowl in 53 it was 36 the last time a
rest of the day look to the day Wow
which may which makes it even more
fitting that Brady would win and walk
away to factors with Brady guys one his
wife has been pushing this issue of
walking away for a while now she kind of
jokingly but I think kind of seriously
wanted him to retire after Super Bowl 51
when they came back from down 28 to 3
and also in big cat we've talked about
this before on pardon my take the idea
that Brady talks about playing 245 so he
never has a farewell year so when he's
done he just says I'm done and they
never go through that experience for him
for everyone he doesn't want it to be
about him of that one last year so he
always has that stake so far out in the
ground that you never realize it's his
last year until his last year is over
that could end up being this year if
they win and then the on the flip side
the
part of me that says this probably won't
be his last year is that he I think he
genuinely wants to not only play
football for more years but he wants to
create this TB 12 and the you know gyms
across America and all this stuff that
he's doing yeah
it significantly hampers him if he stops
playing football yeah I mean there could
be some truth to that TB 12 and what
he's doing in that along those lines it
is special it's I mean it's amazing
really but he's doing all together what
we gonna say Mike go ahead
no he's the living breathing billboard
for TB 12 right longer he plays the more
he proves that these methods work
because he keeps getting order and he
keeps playing well yeah and that would
be a reason to go to 42 43 44 45 and who
knows maybe even beyond that
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports